it is nice to have so many people even
in the afternoon
and yeah this is not a particularly a
technical topic because I won't be
talking about really much technical
details but rather what uh developing a
package can could bring you as a team
when you're working in a in a company
and first of all hi I'm Andre I am core
developer of Open Source uh time series
for custom package called Aetna Aetna is
not developed by SML it was developed by
my previous team when I worked where I
worked previously but it doesn't really
matter because now it's open source
Library
and why do we have packages and before
uh we I start talking about my
experience I'd like to clarify some
details add some definitions by package
we usually mean a box of frequently used
features and classes and like something
like that but it is not particularly
true because we also introduced some
complexity some abstract models some set
of rules so this package uh will be
easier to understand by external users
and uh
we create those rules uh for solving a
specific tasks and yes basically
every package is unique because it is uh
designed to solve uh diff different
tasks it could be focused on tasks like
solving uh
forecasting forecasting problems or it
could be like circuit learn really broad
way of usage really common package that
could be used by many uh Developers for
many problems and we also could uh have
different methods in our package like in
circuit learn psychic learn has a lot of
models a lot of algorithms like
and basically you can do anything with
it if you try hard enough uh but
you also have packages that have very
specific methods for example by torch
forecasting package has only neural
networks to solve really specific tasks
solving only forecasting problems on the
time series and xgboost for example yes
it has only boosting models but it could
solve really different different tasks
with it and
the idea is that all of these packages
have different abstract layers abstract
model set of rules how they're written
and everything and we should also have
to keep in mind uh that and how to make
a package and
I'm not saying about making a package
like as a person because as a person you
may have a desire to write a package and
you basically
um there's no one to stop you from doing
that but when you're working in a
company as a team
you have somehow to justify why would
you need a such a such a war
and in my opinion the best business
structure to create a package is when
your team your machine learning team is
in the middle of everything like you
have different business clients coming
to you asking like we need to create a
model we need to create data Pipeline
and like we they come into you asking
you to solve for them different
I don't know machine learning data
related use cases and you provide them
with such uh pipelines with such models
and uh
uh in our cases we just collected our
use cases
and basically all of them was about were
about
forecasting something we either
forecasted some uh phone calls uh
deliveries or service requests and even
though we had
different models different steps in our
pipelines basically we did similar
things over and over again and if we try
and if we decompose them we could really
construct an abstract model that says us
like you have this step after that you
perform this step then you apply machine
learning model then you do your
validation and putting it in production
so it somehow
we got an idea that maybe we could a bit
automate this process uh make it easier
for us
and we also uh got our requirements not
from our use cases but also from inside
the team because it is really important
uh because when you develop in a package
uh your team is the first user of this
package and basically you need this
package to be as much comfortable to use
as possible because yeah you're
basically a developer of this package
and a consumer at the same time and yes
uh below the requirements I have like
this mental model abstract model of how
our forecasting pipelines usually look
like and after that
um
you should just start writing everything
and start writing your drafts uh putting
uh every step in the right position
every step of your different use cases
for your different pipelines in the
right position and at this point you
really have to convince your project
manager to believe in you because you
because you're spending time on doing
things that already is done and you have
to convince this person who gives you
time that this work is essential that
this work could be beneficial not only
for uh the team uh not only for the
developers but also for business and
when you do that uh well you could
actually add more features
and it will be easier than before and
what are the benefits how we convinced
uh our project manager basically we said
that well all the use cases will be
equally tested because you write this
package you test this function this
class and you use it across different
pipelines and after that
whenever you use it once more it is
already tested in in the package
everyone in the in your team will know
how to work with this package because
everyone at some point will participate
in development they will have some
understanding houses built what abstract
models we use and it is actually uh a
good idea to have all this Collective
effort put in one place and not put in
different pipelines across your team and
this will result in faster and better
deployments because uh actually you can
when you have a new use case you get you
can basically apply an old pipeline to
the new data and probably the more use
cases you have done previously
uh the high probability that this result
will be uh really good enough and also
after we uh build this draft after we
build we also got some unexpected
benefits we did not expect that
basically we
uh stopped writing python code for our
new use cases because we had uh
configuration files
we just specified input data output
destination uh the whole pipeline as a
yaml config file and we had Docker image
with a library that could read this file
and produce a result basically it was uh
easier than before and also we had
similar logging strategies across all
the different use cases and we can
easily find the source of the problem
and
for example if we if you also use some
uh log aggregation Services it is easier
to query those logs to find these
problems to calculate metrics on on
on your pipelines to see how they
perform too basically it was good enough
but this always seems so good on the
slides when someone presenting to you
that we did great on the first try but
no that's not how it looks in real life
basically uh we uh did not grade in our
architecture and we introduced a bad
architectural pattern called the cat
object uh basically that's how it looked
like when we had a small amount of
features we had this small class called
Data Handler which should have ringed
the Bell even at the at the time when we
created class called Data Handler what
does it do I don't know uh but no it we
were not as experienced back then and
the more features we added the more code
we should uh we should have added to
data Handler and we and when we changed
code in our data Handler we have to
change code that were previously written
in other uh this pieces
and the more features were added the
more time we had to spend on adding on
on adding all these changes across all
our code base
and at some point we thought maybe
refactoring is not such a bad idea
but we were satisfied with our
architecture with our like not
architecture but we were satisfied with
our functionality the business uh liked
uh how we work because uh we could
faster uh
intake new use cases but for us adding
new features more like really painful
and we come to the product manager and
ask for some time to do the refactoring
and because we didn't done good
previously we were allowed to have time
to do the refactoring
and uh we we actually looked at the
architecture decomposed them like we saw
exactly what parts uh doing what work
and uh trying to construct a better
abstract model and I have a an advice
how to do this perfectly basically you
should put Diamond effort in this
process there's actually no Silver
Bullet here like you should do a lot of
brainstorming with other people so your
ideas will will be tested against like
reality you should actually learn design
patterns
if you haven't done so at University
you should also write some drafts to see
if this idea is actually working and do
that over and over again until you're
satisfied with your work and you could
explain to other people that it really
makes sense because because at some
point you will be so cut up with your
ideas
uh that it will will look like a good
solution but in reality it won't work so
you have to include
other people in it
and
yeah basically after the refactoring we
got this actually the same pipeline than
before uh well also we've had like exact
same steps but uh uh because we
made our library
cleaner and easier for us to develop we
were able to introduce even new module
called analysis that allowed us to uh
plot results uh plot metrics like
analyze the time series
and the benefits of all this work done
because it was long it was one process
because we were not only developing and
refactoring but we also were adding some
new features is that we actually had a
proper unit tests across all our code
base
we had an onboarding documentation for
new users and most importantly because
we did this deconstruction of our use
cases so far
of our architecture of how we use and
write code we again the better domain
understanding about Time series
business and that had on the other hand
got faster uh faster intake of new use
cases and also they got an idea that if
they have some problems with the time
series so they want to forecast them or
analyze them they could come to us
because we know our stuff and actually
that was like beneficial for both
parties
uh but actually when does open source
come into a play and I don't have any
idea how this happened because it was
just an idea that maybe we should open
source a package and management said why
why not let's uh test this idea to see
what will happen and we open sourced it
and by uh using this QR code you can
find this
package and also my uh contacts but also
again if you're working with time series
because the package is only focused for
time series forecasting and the
presentation is not about creating a
Time series package you're at about
creating like any package
and yeah but what we gain by open
sourcing this uh
but by open source now work actually we
gained even better documentation because
now we did not have to explain us
explain us what the package is capable
of but to explain other people why they
should use our package to work with uh
to solve the their time series problem
how this package is constructed what
parts does it has and and the staff and
basically like everything and yes it
requires a lot of work and effort to
build the documentation but
the onboarding process when you team
members is as easy as possible as it was
before
I also we had to uh
create better processes like uh
explaining what this task is about uh
explaining how a code review is how code
review process is going and also we had
to create like many cicd steps and four
pipelines when we do new releases when
we uh
add new features uh we actually have to
write a lot of tests to see if this will
work actually
and the
you start right better quote but you you
start using dog test you start using
linters formatters a lot and even
signature linkers that's uh the best I
guess because they uh they see that your
documentation is uh
is uh connected to to the signature of
the function in reality and not and and
not that yes function has documentation
well it's fine to go no it it checks if
all the arguments is there
uh and what we got in return well
actually GitHub stores which is really
satisfying process
like you for the first few weeks you
just constantly reload the page and it's
like wow 10 Stars I'm popular
sometimes people will actually commit
something to your library like once a
month or something
and your PR department and your company
could also use this to make hiring
process easier or to use uh something
for I don't know for example we
forecasted uh uh how many how much how
many flowers will people buy
uh during Saint Valentine's holiday for
example and they published an article
about it that was cited by like uh every
uh media in in a country I guess and
also it is easier to communicate with
the community as well because now you
not just working for a company but also
developing something uh and people uh
start talking to you
voluntarily you don't have to force them
to talk to you
uh but yeah it's actually
um
it's actually feels really different uh
and
you could share their ideas uh and
that's important in development I guess
and well in conclusion even though we
open source the package it's not a
philanthropy because the company uh also
gained some activities they not like
instant uh they kind of work in the long
run and the package development also
works in the long run because uh like
you have to spend several
weeks months developing it but in in a
long time you will it will allow you to
work faster than before
it also makes processes better because
you include every member of the team
into these processes and they share the
ideas how to make them even better and
that's uh good uh
when you compare it where usually like
team lead thinks of processes and you
kind of maintain those processes but you
do not
but you not in the loop of improving
them
and ironically this package development
allows you to spend more time on code
because one code block now uh is more
important because it used in uh
different pipelines and you have to test
it more you have to make sure everyone
and team understands it you have to add
documentation you have to make sure that
it is not like have I don't know 10 for
Loops for example I don't know
and also some unexpected benefits for us
it was about uh configuration files
docking containers and logging and for
other I don't know teams it could be
about any anything else and
I guess to experience this unexpected
benefits we just have to give it a try
writing our package and that's all for
me
[Applause]
inspiring story thank you I was just
curious how long did it take you to move
the package from um yeah like in-house
to open source uh one year
okay yeah so yeah quite a bit of work
but yeah I guess it pays off it well it
was not about development like
development the first draft took uh me
about uh
I don't know a one one and a half month
uh and then we added some new features
then we had refactoring time again for
one and a half months and then we uh
open sourced it
so very cool
are there more questions from the
audience
thanks for your talk uh I do have a
technical question okay what is your
package building uh program is it
flipped or or poetry and why just just
interested
uh well we use uh poetry uh because uh
it really nicely solve solves these
requirements we really like that and it
also allow us to like build the package
easily
and uh well that's just a nice package I
really recommend it
how did you get all your stars so I see
you've got 649 Stars I'll give you one
I'll give you a star after the if you
answer the question well okay
um I'm curious so you build a great
package you put it out there how do you
get people to to start using it uh
basically that's uh I guess that's a
topic for even one more presentation
because it's uh what after the open
source in the package it's not about the
development of the package anymore it's
about a communication with people using
it like describing how to use the
package releasing some maybe some
articles about it in in medium or
something like that coming to the
conferences like this so you will give
us a star and maybe other people also
will that's how we gain the Stars yeah
thank you
yeah thank you I have a question you
said you had the
um or you started while incorporating
use cases from the internal customer
from internet business and from my
experience this means that you have a
lot of data wrangling and like customer
business specific code in these
pipelines did you remove that from uh
like this this specific data wrangling
Park part from the package or is it
included or how did you approach that uh
well when you start merging you
different use cases you actually find
out that the data for different use
cases looks quite different and you have
somehow to standardize it and when you
standardize it you kind of remove all
the details about the data itself so
basically there is no uh case specific
details in the in a package because uh
otherwise it wouldn't work for other use
cases
I I hope I answered your question okay
and uh there's one more question here
yeah so you mentioned uh an
architectural anti-pattern right the god
object but yeah so and you also
mentioned I believe but correct me if
I'm wrong that you partially solved that
by engaging in this brainstorming
process and and this iterative process
I've experienced the exact opposite
where we had these anti-patterns engaged
in that process and it became much worse
so I am not fully convinced that that is
the solution so maybe we can dig a bit
deeper into that so what specifically
did you do to get that on track um
basically yes you have to have someone
in charge of this architecture process
but then this person should align with
the other team members to uh validate
his ideas even so you have not only
brainstormed together but also come to
in conclusion and brainstorm over like
your ideas to find like weak points in
it
um how does um how does testing factor
in like when do you test and what
because you say you need to validate
right that sounds like testing to me so
how how did you approach that
uh basically uh you try to construct
some uh use case uh with your new model
and see what will happen if we add like
more features or if we add uh if we
throw in like I don't know more models
uh and if if a pipeline is very long
like we have uh I don't know 100
features what will happen to to the code
base
and uh
basically like you uh look at different
use cases you try to find uh at this
point this could go wrong for example if
you
have
uh
need to add like new model to some
categories and some to some class to to
to some to some other class that means
that it's tightly coupled and at some
point you will have to
uh refactor it again and
um
also uh when you work with different
models they have different like inputs
different parameters different
everything like for example boosting
models profit models and neural network
and uh when you solve this
with some other class that will uh
handle all this work and not buy an
abstraction model for example what what
you like wrap your model uh
and that means that it's kind of bad
situation because you will you will
actually create one more this gut object
a little bit of a follow-up then and how
did you prioritize what to test so
which validation was most important how
did you figure that out with your team
uh well basically we figured out that uh
each class should not look into the
internals of any different in in any
other class and it should only expect
input as a data and the output has a
data and nothing more
thanks
so now you have a package and you have a
community using it do you have a like a
long-term contingency plan how do you
make sure that if your for example your
employer
loses interest maybe in the package or
the package becomes less essential to
your work how do you make sure it stays
alive
uh well that's a hard question because
there's no right answer and at the
moment I don't really have like any
long-term plan for supporting
but I think if the community finds this
package like important it will and at
some case try to keep it alive
uh but yeah that's an important question
yeah
well if there are no more questions
please give him a last round of applause
and some GitHub Stars